il a de qui tenir il a une belle gueule
il a une pêche maximum on parle de lui
pour des missions à la télé voici
ludovic chancel
est ce que ton en soif de vie qu'est ce
que ton voyage entre le temps et
l'espace s'est bien passé d'abord
bonsoir puis maintenant il y avait
quelques perturbations
alors tu connais le principe de cette
émission c'est à dire le passé le
présent l'avenir alors on va commencer
tout simplement par ton parfois passer
cette fait quel âge 19 ans ça rajeunit
personne parce que tu es le fils de
sheila et ringo
est ce que tu veux qu'on regarde un
petit peu l'album de famille pour
commencer tu me laisses le choix oui non
rigides
je vous rappelle leslie gondoles à
venise et à ne pas confondre avec l'ess
limon gueule en tout cas merci mille
fois hélas pour cette semaine moi je te
laisse avec ringo mais là je ne te dis
pas d'être sérieuse
et ces compagnies
nouveau palais
owni
mais sont loin
et
seul
la folie
et
violet pourquoi tu porte le nom de ta
mère parce que c'est elle qui m'a éduqué
c'est un peu par respect voilà tout
simple c'est pas parce que tu serais le
fils de jacques chancel parle alors
aucun de tes parents nehru tuer ou sa si
jolie d'ailleurs que les yeux verts
c'est assez beau gosse tu fais une
avance là c'est clair non
il ya des animateurs des idées qui ne
sont pas il faut bien se le dire il
ya l'école c'est ce que c'est comment
souvent personne de chanter les tubes de
ta mère l'aurait cru on n'en sait pas
encore de pierre quoi maintenant une
question 2 pire ça peut être aussi les
chanter non non mais il savait que
chance elle s'était montrée ne faisait
pas un rapprochement
ouais ouais c'était plutôt jacques
chancel donc reste bien ce que je
pensais est-ce que c'est pas pire ou là
c'est t'aider à te faire des copains et
le fils de celle là quand tu étais petit
nom s'il n'ya pas trop marqué le fils de
cher ouais tu veux mais tu t'en caché à
la non je me cachais pas mais je disais
pas spécialement cette idée a tapé des
gonzesses s'est jamais vraiment bars à
lait
comme disait baffie et ya vécu comment
la séparation de ses parents
mais si j'étais très jeune alors j'ai
pas une grande notion de la séparation
c'est qu'on a à peu près deux ans c'est
quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas arrivé
tempère tu le vois toujours non plus
jamais ça plus jamais on sait pas ce que
l'avenir nous réserve
ouais on verra bien fait quoi maintenant
je n'en sais rien
est ce à ce point là et avec la mère
comment ça va lui se voit plus
je crois pas qu'il se voit non je pense
pas c'est le séparation totale et
définitive quoi tu penses quoi de la
carrière de ta mère j'espère avoir le
dixième de succès qu'elle a eu ça c'est
clair
oui mais beaucoup de succès je connais
carey représente claude carrère son
pygmalion qui n'a pas proposé de te
produire à ton tour
non il n'a pas proposé mais je suis pas
sûr que je vais accepter gevrey c'est
quoi la chanson d'elle que tu préfères
par exemple allez je vais être
complètement catégorique c'est
à temps j'hésite un petit peu parce
qu'on a deux qui ne tient pas à quoi bon
se dit à l'école est finie l'école est
finie moi tu la connais cette chanson je
me dois chan prépa pourquoi parce que
j'ai pas du tout envie
[Applaudissements]
jean-claude oh ouais bah voila vous la
connaissez pas celle-là vous l'école est
finie de shay la wii donne moi ta main
et sans réel
la votation les
et les filles la rue est à nous
mais oui mais oui les gars les fils
barbelés
et dans ce cas il y en a 10 19 quant à
mr a essayé de faire latter tu as trouvé
cinq bons très courageux tricot adjoint
c'était pas facile à cause des
producteurs qui la produisent et ou à
cause du fait de faire de la télé non à
cause du fer de phase va t elle croit la
réincarnation j'ai lu dans le journal
dans cette journée devrait être
intéressé va justement alors il serait
tout à fait à l'aise dans cette émission
vous school seniors tps
non non ce qui en reste elles sinon nous
d'howick nous d'howick chancel tencel
c'est pas tes pdac ludwig chancel c'est
fidel castro qui cherche populaire
non non non non non non non adios
alors on va passer au présent maintenant
là on a vu tout le passé alors passé au
présent donc la première fois que tu as
eu envie d'être star c'est quand t'as vu
ta mère pour la première fois sur scène
au zénith c'est ça voilà c'est vrai que
ça m'a donné envie de faire ce métier
bon de l'aed star pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs où on verra ce qui va
se passer
fatal physique déjà je peux dire non
mais je suis pas fait 10 ans dès qu'on
va trouver avec vous en êtes repéré
basile cardiaque et leur tube ac plus
quoi je suis pas bacs j'suis rock'n'roll
avant d'accord tu penses quoi des
lycéens qui défilent dans la rue en
criant balader enlève ton si je pense
que je suis de tout coeur avec toi aussi
voilà on m'a très bien
c'est le côté michel field de cette
émission après tout tu penses quoi des
casseurs
je pense que c'est pas la meilleure
solution pour résoudre des problèmes
ouais le progrès le magnétoscope si je
te marier ouais c'est jacqueline car en
vue stop vie privée et vie privée
voilà un bon d'accord mais je comprends
pas c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
intéressant la vie prix bayeux store oui
je peux encore connus devraient
s'informer de mon avis on va voir la
dépêche toi d'être reconnu par tous nous
poser la question oui je tiens une
question à laquelle tu veux bien
mais alors tu peux faire de la tv
pourquoi pas médecins du monde parce que
je pense que je suis pas fait pour ça
ouais
et puis je sais pas moi bon verre à la
télé tu vois tu veux commencer par la
télé puis ça marche pas tu feras
médecins du monde
vraiment si ça marche pas ouais vraiment
ton modèle d'animateurs ce serait plutôt
drucker absolument sudo naître frédéric
et pourquoi pas à tes vrais bien être
freinée
est ce que tu aimerais bien être arthur
non est-ce que ça va bien être christian
session qui a question qui crie sur qui
non non non c'était pour voir si c'est
au tour du canton dit frédéric ils
demandent pas si c'est le terran mais
quand on dit christian il sait pas que
c'est mort 1
est ce que tu voudras est georges beller
preuve est ce que tu voudrais et
alexandre debanne
bon écoute on était assez torturé comme
ça on va passer à l'avenir donc mais
pourquoi tu personne de thierry ardisson
pourra me dédierai maintenant on va
passer à l'avenir donc tu veux faire la
télévision alors imagine coup de
baguette magique thierry ardisson a été
viré justement une fois de plus et si et
qu il reçoit tu dis ce soir je reçois un
has been
je reçois thierry ardisson alors on va
changer de place je viens t'asseoir ici
j'aime m'asseoir là et tu vas me poser
des questions d'accord on y va quand je
te prends mon verre
thierry bonnefoi je suis terrorisée
c'était journaliste au canard enchaîné
quel animateur de tv tu rêverais
d'épingler ardisson il a une telle
grande gueule j'ai vu tellement chez
tout le monde que j'aimerais bien le
regarder il ya quelques mois ils y sont
arrivés ils s'en sont pas privés je
pense que c'est ardisson que j'aimerais
par une accord on dit partout que tu va
produire savatier et que tu vas laisser
tomber bravo et ma fille ouais ça ne
gêne pas les changer un baril de
scandale contre 2 barry d'impertinence
écoute d'abord sabatier jeu le
produirait si la chaîne décide de
travailler avec lui ce qui ne dépend pas
de moi mais si la si c'est le cas je le
ferai volontiers christine bravo c'est
vrai que c'est un peu terminée parce que
froufrous s'arrête en juin quant à ma
fille le jour il aura compris qu'il vaut
mieux faire 50 % d'une bonne affaire que
100% une mauvaise je produirai avec
plaisir voilà auquel personnalité à part
toi même as-tu le plus d'atomes et de
respect j'aime beaucoup daniel
filipacchi quelle interview que tu
regrettes d'avoir fait
vas-y basse et une interview je me suis
un peu de son nom la suite était tout
raser la comment il s'appelait jimmy
sommerville et celle que je regrette de
ne pas avoir fait c'est john lennon mais
je crois que ça va se régler rapidement
on va te dématérialisée mon petit ça
fait mal non pour éviter des habitudes
abonnez vous il était impossible
[Applaudissements]